[Música]
el gobierno de venezuela continúa
censurando a la prensa local
específicamente a los medios de
comunicación digitales la sociedad
interamericana de prensa condenó la
agresión cibernética contra medios y
periodistas el presidente de la comisión
de la libertad de prensa e información
de la sip
carlos fornet se refirió a informes
internacionales que desde hace varias
décadas subrayan la importancia de la
libertad de prensa en el ciberespacio
condenó en especial las restricciones
gubernamentales a la libertad de
expresión en internet en países como
cuba del salvador y venezuela y para
contrarrestar esta censura los medios
digitales de venezolanos ahora
distribuyen la información por otros
canales como telegram y whatsapp quiere
salvar entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado el día del es carlos correa
director ejecutivo de espacio público y
profesor investigador del centro de
derechos humanos de la universidad
católica andrés bello gracias profesor
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa le pregunto primero que nada la
situación actual de la libertad de
prensa en venezuela
bueno básicamente
venezuela actualmente se sufre
las consecuencias de una política
restrictiva en el informe de venezuela
hay alrededor de 980 medios alrededor
del 80% de esos medios son emisoras de
radio y televisión que están sometidas a
una regulación muy fuerte por parte de
conatel que el órgano regulador o el
órgano que administra el espectro
radioeléctrico y él después estos son
los espacios de libertad donde de alguna
manera circula información
son los medios digitales o las
plataformas digitales porque los
periódicos en venezuela se han
restringido venezuela circulaban
alrededor de 100 días adiós de alrededor
debe estar saliendo alrededor de una
docena de diarios y no todos los días
sino una vez a la semana y con
circulaciones muy restringidas entonces
eso hace que todo lo que tiene que ver
con internet no sea todo lo que tenga
que ver con restricciones de internet
tiene unas consecuencias muy fuertes
porque es el canal en el que circula
información o mayor información de
calidad es estadista quien circula en
algunos programas de radio pero como ya
decía antes con muchas limitaciones o
restricciones porque hay una supervisión
muy cercana por parte de conatel ahora
profesor le quiero preguntar por qué
acceder a nuestros bloqueos no que busca
ocultar en este caso el gobierno de
nicolás maduro
bueno a ver ahí hay varios tipos de
bloqueo algunos tienen que ver con
denuncias de corrupción es decir muchos
de estos portales dan información sobre
temas de corrupción por ejemplo los
casos del caso famoso de otra vez por
ejemplo o situaciones vinculadas a las
investigaciones que se están dando en
distintos lugares del mundo o temas
vinculados a la corrupción y las casas
que todo eso genera en muchas veces que
se restrinjan los medios también hay
como una una obsesión gubernamental por
controlar o administrar la información
que circula en venezuela entonces lo que
hacen es promover una oferta vinculada a
lo que son las cadenas o las plataformas
gubernamentales el control de algunos
medios privados que antes eran
independientes y tratar de restringir al
máximo cualquier tipo de información que
pueda ser
sensible o crítica a la gestión
gubernamental
básicamente lo que se persigue es
silenciar las cosas química claros los
beneficiando así también como lo hacía
el entonces el presidente hugo chávez
que mandaba pues estas cadenas
presidenciales cuando a lo mejor salida
a los medios de comunicación resaltaba
una información que no estaba a favor de
él el mandatario cuando él cuando hugo
chávez era presidente pero ahora le
pregunto con toda esta situación es tan
adversa para operar la libertad de
prensa en venezuela como están haciendo
los medios independientes para poder
existir para poder seguir haciendo su
labor
bueno una de las cosas que nosotros
hacemos es un monitoreo de la situación
de libertad de expresión yo lo revisa el
año pasado por ejemplo el año 2021
nosotros documentamos
246 casos eso significa que hay todavía
un músculo en la sociedad venezolana que
quiere seguir informado la sociedad
venezolana también está buscando
información como está buscando bueno
básicamente por las rendijas que quedan
en base de por ejemplo los medios han
tenido que establecer algunos de estos
medios digitales portales espejo es
decir portales que replican la
información para que algunas personas
puedan leerla pero que no la lean en el
mismo sitio eso tiene unas consecuencias
económicas porque los sitios entonces
reflejan menos tráfico y por lo tanto es
posible que tengan menos anuncios
después están circulando información por
correo electrónico o por redes como
whatsapp hay una una actividad muy
importante de circulación de información
en plataformas y redes sociales como
twitter o facebook entonces hay una
dinámica de circulación de información
que de alguna manera está corriendo por
esa vía
se desean por plataformas de mensajería
o sea por plataformas basadas en
internet y después hay también el
crecimiento de algunas dinámicas de
comunicación más bien presencial que por
supuesto todas estas no tienen el
equivalente a lo que pueden ser medios
audiovisuales libres que puedan hacer
todo su trabajo los periódicos que
tienen una función muy importante en la
definición de las agendas pero están
haciendo que la sociedad venezolana
búsqueda socialmente información así que
hay un encuentro de una sociedad que
tiene información de calidad y
periodistas que tratan de hacer el
trabajo a pesar de todas las
limitaciones profesor le quiero
preguntar entonces si en este contexto y
cómo está el panorama contra la prensa
en venezuela se pueden esperar más
represalias contra otros medios de
comunicación más bloqueos
día
pero que así es y no hay ningún
indicador de que haya variaciones sobre
el comportamiento estatal más bien lo
que ha venido pasando en los últimos dos
años es que ha empezado a aplicarse en
acciones represivas por la circulación
de información realmente quería como
whatsapp ya empezamos a ver casos en los
que se persigue a personas que hacen
circular información en grupos de pasada
o se han tratado de castigar también a
personas que utilizan redes sociales
como twitter entonces yo creo que hay
una lo que están cambiando son
aquí está persiguiendo se están
incorporando nuevos actores pero no creo
que haya elementos de variación ahora si
hay una situación de movilización o de
inquietud a nivel de la cotidianidad yo
estoy seguro de que van a aumentar como
ocurrió en enero de este año a propósito
de las elecciones en el estado barinas
hay alguien me llama la atención
profesor y si se le quiero preguntar eso
de cómo se mantienen estos medios
digamos de dónde vienen los recursos
porque además estamos hablando de que
hay una publicidad restringido en la
publicidad limitada esto con lo de los
medios espejos que usted estaba
comentando cómo se mantiene
era allí en distintas modalidades por un
lado algunos de estos medios han
empezado a presentar propuestas en
organismos de cooperación internacional
de diversa naturaleza que especialmente
para coberturas de temas de derechos
humanos situación de temas ambientales o
incluso temas de transparencia se pueden
conseguir los recursos otros están
haciendo modalidades de membresía es
decir personas que se hacen miembros de
los grupos que apoyan a estos medios y
eso junto con esos medios mucho más
chicos la medio mucho más no son medios
tan grande tome en cuenta por ejemplo
que un diario regional en venezuela
podría tener 400 empleados y muchas de
estas plataformas
tienen pueden ser 10 12 ó 15 o 20
personas en el tema de escala y un tema
también de que se han empezado a
utilizar otro tipo de modalidades para
sostener al periodismo por otro lado ese
no es un tema único en venezuela es es
un desafío
el mundo decir cómo se financia el
periodismo gráfica especialmente por
todos los cambios que se han venido
dando rápidamente ya profesor para
finalizar nuestra conversación quiero
tocar el tema del nacional y la demanda
que le interpuso diosdado cabello cómo
va esto
es a su caso que tiene ya varios años yo
nada más quiero recordar rápidamente de
qué se trata hay una información que
recuerdo un periódico en eeuu es
replicada por varios medios entre ellos
un medio español el diario abc y 13
medios en venezuela la réplica
básicamente dice que se estaban haciendo
algunas investigaciones en eeuu sobre
presunta corrupción de diosdado cabello
diosdado cabello hace una demanda penal
y después hace una demanda civil por
pretendido daño moral y se concentró en
tres medios de comunicación en nacional
la patilla y el diario talcual
y básicamente diosdado cabello se ha
enseñado con el diario nacional una
decisión establecía un monto en el daño
moral y después lo llevó a 13 millones
de dólares pues a 30 millones de dólares
y eso es el argumento pretendido claure
el que se lea
las instalaciones del diario 'el
nacional' entonces por supuesto eso
tiene un impacto muy fuerte porque
genera un efecto silenciamiento porque
se ve eso como como el caso testigo de
lo que le puede ocurrir a alguien que
haga cobertura sobre esos temas y además
se amenaza con atacar o cuestionar la
plataforma digital del diario 'el
nacional' entonces es una situación en
la que básicamente se ve una
desproporción absoluta por sencillamente
replicar una información que el reportar
en este caso firme de una información
este y que además evidentemente es de
interés público y profesor curiosamente
también en estos tres medios de
comunicación más críticos al gobierno de
laura el presidente nicolás maduro
gracias profesor por estar con nosotros
en directo américa un gran abrazo desde
la ciudad de bogotá